demi lovato still in the hospital the
one surprising person constantly by her
side Nikki Bella gets emotional over
John Cena Plus et is backstage with Luke
Bryan
[Music]
happy Monday friends this is the daily
Denny with the latest on Demi Lovato's
recovery et has learned that she woke up
this morning still in the hospital
six days after her drug overdose we're
told the singer is experiencing nausea
and fever and a source tells ET quote
she's under the care of medical
professionals and is expected to recover
by her side Demi's ex Wilmer Valderrama
a source also tells ET Wilmer has been a
constant source of support for her since
she OD quote he visits Demi every day he
can and has spent hours with her and her
family she and Wilmer split in 2016
after six years together but it goes
without saying that these two held on to
their strong bond and back last year
Demi posed for a pic with Wilmer at a
party and wrote best of friends no
matter what and here's what she told
et's Kelty night last year about their
possible future i value my time by
myself now and i value my time with my
friends
then seeing all this footage of you guys
I was like I kind of want them at the
end
possibility can we hang on to that for
like a few more years you never know
what's gonna happen and I don't know
what's gonna happen
I've always loved Demi Woolmer together
but obviously her health is the priority
here and our source says Wilmer is just
trying to be a solid friend to her right
now
meanwhile the jury is still out on
whether Nikki Bella and John Cena will
get back together but last night's total
Bella's season finale revealed just
where the relationship fell apart
apparently it's when she was finalizing
wedding details without John five weeks
before they were supposed to say I do
when you have a relationship in the
public eye it's like you don't want to
let your fans down and everyone's fairy
tale was John and I getting married like
Superman and Wonder Woman finally found
each other and this is everyone's
happily ever after
so you just force yourself to believe it
too even if you start feeling something
different the first time they called it
quits was in January and we were whipped
John at Comic Con just last week where
he was promoting his new movie bumblebee
it's very he played coy about possible
reconciliations this is the master
that's gonna win her back all right but
switching gears now to Luke Bryan the
country star lived on a lifelong dream
over the weekend playing one of the most
iconic venues and baseball stadiums in
the world Luke is the first country
artist to headline and sellout Dodger
Stadium with his what makes you country
excel tour and guess what I was there
here's meeting Luke backstage and I
don't even listen to country music you
guys but Joe wouldn't know it he turned
Dodger Stadium into a party and I had a
freaking blast et's Kevin Frazier was
with Luke just before he hit the stage
to talk about the impact of Luke's
latest single
[Music]
first time did I'm got a promotional
copy or album we listen to most people
are gonna ride my wife and she says did
he just say did is is he saying that you
love who you love I believe you love who
you love I love that and it caught her
attention and I think it's caught a lot
of people's attention that it's been
good that you are really promoting a
message of diversity in that song it's a
beautiful scene yeah I mean when I heard
that song I thought about you know I
thought about every level of humanity
and what that line does I felt like that
it could be translated in taken in so
many ways and people were going to hear
that and and hear a country music
artists do it and go they were yeah I
mean it man I tell you I mean standing
on that stage every night watching
people sing that song together watch it
people yeah I've said it many times
every line of that song has a tremendous
purpose and a tremendous Beauty to it
but then you know here in the line I
believe you love who you love you know
it ain't nothing you should ever be
ashamed of I mean I'm watching people
sing that together watching country fans
sing that together it makes me proud it
makes me proud that I could that I could
find a song record a song and
performance and you're making a
difference out there in the world and
you know I've been accused of some of my
music not making a difference
potentially you know hurting your IQ do
you drink some beers but but you know
these are most people are good it's just
a special song that that you know it's
not about whether country music artists
did it who ever would have performed
that song I think it would have touched
a lot of people I think if you're gonna
blaze your own Trail at any form of
putting yourself out there you know
you're not gonna make everybody happy
you have to you have to
I guess polarity or whatever you have to
be a little bit polarizing you can't be
cookie cutter and I'm really really
happy at I mean you look at Dodger
Stadium thank you lord I mean that is
direct reflection of bringing everybody
to the party Thanks for seeing us Luke
I'm a fan now all right for more with
Luke tune into ET tonight and head over
to our website ET online.com and I'll
see y'all tomorrow